so what's this new character you keep
yapping about okay so there's this guy
whoa there's like an elemental Mage he's
really hard he's really squishy oh cool
this guy is like the sword mercenary guy
I got that guy and then this is the new
guy whoa what is that his left click is
a triple shot unlimited ammo the third
shot a leech's life his right click is
like a mortar you give up 15 of your
health but you launch a mortar for 450
damage and it's like infinite range
interesting that's cool
so I'll show you we have to play the
game and I can show you all right are we
playing on normal difficulties okay
rainstorm I guess it's called normal's
good cool let's do this here we go
distant Roost that's us it's been a
while since I've played I don't quite
remember all right so to get the new
character the first thing is you have to
go to the back of your pod and there's a
little door hit e on it and you'll open
the door
ooh and then get that thing
cool I got a fuel already oh it takes up
your item spot we have to find a
specific guy in like the fourth world to
do something we should not even make it
past the fourth world oh we will we can
make it we're good at this game now
right but anyway keep that and if you go
below 50 Health
um you explode so don't wait what do you
do that what or no not below 50. if you
go below some relatively low amount of
Health you explode so don't do that that
sounds bad okay but you have to do it to
get the thingy oh but don't don't lose
your health oh there's also instead of
just chest being chest they're they're
Chum some of them will be types so this
is like a healing item chest that one
you just open weight is just like a
random item but so there are healing
utility and I think attack holy [ __ ] so
what's the health thing we want uh so
it's just a health chest it'll have a
health item in it
well okay what I I my character needs
Health items so I didn't know that I was
saving up specifically just to get that
one oh and I did not know that oh okay
I'm not playing since I think we played
last yeah give me the bustling fungi Oh
no I got a q item I can't take it though
because we need these right Bob do you
want this Q item what is it a missile
launcher oh yeah that's good oh God
what's on me what the f what oh oh no oh
no oh the thing the thing the thing it
blew up because I I gave to the shrine
oh you lose it even though you respawn
you lose that now so we can either
restart so Mark can I do you're gonna
know that uh yeah if you don't mind I'm
very dumb I I didn't think of that since
we're doing this that was the new
character but since we're doing this and
we kind of need a carry I'm gonna play
my good character who's that Engineers
Engineers fantastic oh yeah I've heard
engineer is amazing especially so if you
see if you see them that are like little
groups of mushrooms
give me that [ __ ] and make sure you get
the thingy out of your thingy oh I
always get the thingy out of my thingy
what happens when you press Q extremely
unstable I don't actually know you can
try it if you want okay here I go
okay well it did something no it does
nothing oh I found the shrine all right
well don't be too excited about it
good work thank you finally gone some
recognition I've got a little bit of
money to spend and so this way we should
maybe open a couple more things and then
give it a goo I like giving things a goo
give it a goo oh yeah give thanks goo
all the time oh God I'm dead why the
[ __ ] how'd you did I think I got hit
from behind by a floaty while my health
was low God damn I'm getting I'm finding
all of the artifacts on this one all
right yeah let's restart I'm gonna go
back to this lady Huntress is cool
because you don't have to aim which is
pretty chill and I can Sprint at the
same time
pretty chill I need to clearly
hundreds is good Huntress is good just
don't die
everything's fine
why why do you say things like that
because it's fine it's just that when
you say it out of the blue like that it
seems like maybe something's not fine no
so it's not fun it's fine yeah
everything is everything's fine yeah
all right why are you being so
suspicious no you could see how I'm
confused though right you could see you
could see
you could see no I don't think so wait
don't touch the blood thing yeah don't
do the bloodshine I did that no blood
trolling no one not smart thing to do
yeah that was one of the things I
actually thought of on my own okay well
I mean I just had my doubts don't be
don't be [ __ ] let's see if I can time
my blink like I know I can
timed it perfect I'm the best I want
that double jump item what's that called
oh
plastic pigeon something pigeon yeah I
want pigeons or no
yeah feather boo yeah all right I think
that's most of the chest that we could
get I'm not sure though I got a nice
salad oh my God I didn't know that they
did that when they died is that new yeah
that's what happens when they die no
that's new Come On Let's do let's do
this [ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] let's do
this [ __ ] all right boys get close
together I've got a shield for you okay
yeah he thinks he's tough but he hasn't
met us yeah he's coming toward the
shield I don't like that uh it's fine
The Shield's strong oh there I go I went
up
oh he's almost dead oh Shield's gone hey
bye Shield he's almost dead do you know
how health bars work oh dear oh God the
only way to avoid his red laser eye
douchey attack is to break line of sight
so does Wade know what line of sight
line of sight oh he did yeah that wax
Quail get your quails get those quails
my Bros what's it do when you sprint
jump while you're sprinting you get a
like a boost forward uh time to break
some [ __ ] [ __ ]
Bob you put a mine on me I know it's
really cool touch the pig touch the
thing that's the thing touch the tank
touch the stick yeah I did but then the
thingies were sort of
you okay that's what you sounded like
yeah that's what you were like you did
that wait you lose the money when you
transfer yeah lose the gold yeah but
they changed that no no that's outside
no you kept no no no that's not yes no
no you you kept money just keep it from
World the world what no of course you
did you guys are gaslighting me that's
literally the way this game has been
it's also the way the first one wow no
no no no it's it's not a change oh no no
no you really don't remember not having
money no no I had money oh I had money
money power Fame I had it all
out oh God I'm a oh god oh [ __ ] I want
puppet I couldn't move I got bounced
into the guy's ground pound the guy
killed you I got bounced I don't know
what bounced me what
what
I did why just keep going don't don't
don't wait on me can you leave me alone
I think that's the one that killed me
that must be he's real tough I I would
run away he's pretty like Elite I think
that might be like um an admin or
something hacking into our game that's
the only explanation that I died yeah
that's definitely it yeah that was
probably it wait why do you have two
birds huh one of the crates here
um
yeah okay he stole two on the boss
didn't you I did not steal two on the
boss oh here it is wait come here oh big
guy hey Bob
we're not really ready but I'm doing
this oh you sure
there's so much [ __ ] I'm chilling myself
and both my turrets are uh emanating
Healy dudes I wish I had a Healy drone
get up in Bob's area oh yeah okay I've
got a little Health uh Island going on
up here
calm down calm down calm down with that
don't let him suck you oh Bob my [ __ ]
don't let them suck you Boba health is
critically low oh boy I could use this a
friend and me I could got a friend in
you wait where's your where's your
energy thing yeah wait you don't have it
anymore
that's it what wait you don't have your
thing anymore what thing the energy
thing the entire purpose of this oh God
it is gone did it explode but I lived
you'd be dead if it exploded what did
you use it I don't think so well that's
unfortunate all right well might as well
keep going right yeah at this point we
can grind out that thing later me I I'm
willing to maybe admit maybe you didn't
let's keep your gold between
I'm starting to maybe think that maybe
you didn't oh you're willing to admit
the truth now that's good oh don't get
down on me for having a growing moment
and admitting I was wrong growing and
why we
maybe I was wrong and you don't keep
your gold in between oh
you know what that is a growing moment
Mark good job [ __ ] you Wade I'm trying
to be
[ __ ] you I'm being [ __ ] me [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you well [ __ ] you [ __ ] you well [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
you know what Wade Bob to you I believe
that you didn't keep the gold but Wade
to you I don't believe I believe you
kept the gold in between that's what I
believe to you Wade okay that's what I
believe to you that's what's whatever
that's no it's not whatever you
believing wrong things anyway makes me
look better no no no I bet it burns you
up inside I bet it's just roasting your
nuggets I bet yo I bet you really just
toasted all over inside yeah you are
aren't you yeah I could I could feel it
dude toasted them yeah I toasted I told
you I feel mildly warm right now
I'm laughing at the amount of toast I
feel right okay cool good as you should
[ __ ] Yak hey don't be mad about the
yak Buffalo whatever the hell it is why
I didn't say I didn't say you're wrong
about what it was I just said oh God why
did I do that oh I'm allowed to be mad
if I don't know what uh listen man calm
down it's okay no it's not dude dude
chillax oh I did it again I did it I
almost died I keep blowing up those
explodable barrels right next to me
why you ask because I'm very dumb have
we found the uh thingy oh yeah I found
it yeah we hit it uh I guess I want to
go into the case before we do that uh I
did a loop around the caves there's not
much let's just have 1200 bucks to spend
well I got 1200 bucks to spin what's
1200 bucks nothing I just mean that I
have money to spend all these things to
1200 bucks I thought you found something
that cost twelve hundred bucks
1200 bucks get through your thick stuff
oh my God why don't you go suck a buffer
Yak I don't even know what a buffer Yak
is called yakalo you [ __ ] ignorant I
don't think you even have a yakalo
you've seen my yakalo that hurts I you
know what maybe I didn't maybe your
yakolo is a lie like your hair
wow I don't have hair so therefore it
can't be a lie anymore it's a lie to me
you're the worst your diet oh God I got
a bustling I accidentally picked up a
bustling I'm so sorry Bob you I really
yeah we still hear the real friend and
really to me are I'm sorry I just I
instinctively clicked I I'm so sorry and
maybe we should get uh maybe we should
get that I have one turret it will
totally protect us yeah let's go do the
thing go for it hit it oh I'm tickling
it
all right I'm just gonna circle around
here I'll be right down there that's
what they all say oh my God the ax
the ax
oh the Yaks you didn't enunciate the
yeah cause there we go now I understand
mother [ __ ] her standing here lava worm
hey boys we're in for a party the amount
of [ __ ] everywhere sucks whoa ow what
the hell oh you guys are up there oh my
God the lava worm there's a lot of
healing going on up here yeah I got a
nice little healing Fiesta up here and
me too I'm I'm helping the heel with my
fungus
ow
ow okay maybe you're standing here
doesn't seem like the best
oh God oh God Mr worm listen oh God
Mamacitas why not because I said no no
Mamacita's no there you are Wade welcome
to the party I'm bit I've been moving
around have you been hitting the worm
huh but not you've been killing yaks
yeah I don't I don't know how to say
this
I don't know how to say this Wade but
you I think you're you're dragging this
team down okay you say it you're wrong
all right I'm saying it you're dragging
this team down at least I know how the
game looking works oh do you oh okay all
right well I'm saying you don't but you
don't uh well you just said I didn't
so all right I got my old war stealth
kit I got mine I think Wade took two Bob
I think Wade took two I think I got one
he took mine he took the one I was gonna
get no I didn't get mine he took mine he
took mine Bob vote him out of here I
this isn't [ __ ] Survivor
all right so this is the level if either
of you still had the thingy where we do
the thingy oh I wish I did can I get it
back
no it seems it's really hard because
it's like to survive without taking half
of your health that's it's not half but
it's some amount you know I can do it
this character is good for this we
should do it again hey there's a feather
here if one of you jumpy [ __ ] I don't
have one yet I don't have the money for
it I do you don't have the money or you
lied you lied to me oh I'm dead where's
my help still holes want to do a shrine
of combat always every time I need help
right now how much is the feather I
can't even see a price or something yeah
go for it if you want it I won't stop
you
oh man Wade you took it Bob he took I
was right there I was gonna get it he
took it right from under me I hate you
oh he hates me did you hear that I saw
it I saw that [ __ ] yeah what the hell
man I've been nothing but nice to you
yeah that's why I took it oh
geez
he's not am I right
hey look another feather can you guys
kill some stuff for me I need some more
money how about you kill some stuff he's
just he's just using yes Bob hey I need
I need to use you guys for some more
money thank you I got another hoop
feather feather another swampy whoppy no
who
yeah swim it up I know I hear you
right yeah you stinky
you're you're a stadium you're not here
to sniff me I would never sniff you I
would never I would never sniff you
that's offensive I would never sniff you
if you were the last smell on Earth I
would not sniff you what if you were
gonna lose your sense of smell if you
didn't sniff me I'd say goodbye to
sniffing would never not I mean no I'm
dead I was gonna open that I was sitting
here like
what the [ __ ] just happened I don't know
something hit me real hard I think that
trust no Angry that you opened that box
I was like I wish he would just and then
you just explode I just died yeah I just
died I don't know what happened I guess
I get the magazine but thanks for paying
for that you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome
Bob he killed me Bob did you see that um
unbelievable unbelievable
he literally asked for it believable
unbelievable one of my places like hey
wait will you put that bullet up my
rectum and I was like all right man
that's what you want I didn't say that I
didn't say it Bob don't believe him that
was a perfect impression you know that's
exactly what I'm gonna sound like that
sounded exactly I didn't say that I feel
like you did no no if I said that I
would have said it a lot more manly like
put this bullet up my butt I would have
said it again no I no that no that was
me being as if I would say he said it
one more time he wanted me to kill him
even after he's already dead no that no
I wouldn't do that I don't know you just
did Mark on this one wait what
oh yeah I mean yay yeah yeah yeah yeah I
was just side with them you hear that
yeah that's true you didn't want me to
side with you wait at least point in
time Wade's got a good point wait what
point no I I but of course I I know I
want you to side with me because I love
you yeah I know that's why I took your
side man but I love you right oh God
okay
good that's why I'm taking Wayside on
this one wait no you were taking my side
my sweet side Bob I'm at the teleporter
uh I'm coming why don't you ping it Wade
you don't even know how to Ping do you
oh all right let's do this [ __ ] I pinged
it because guess what I know how to pain
yeah right how tell me right now you're
dead guess who's not dead me the peen
Master no in peen what this isn't about
pain what do you say oh yeah who's dead
[ __ ] man if only somebody had something
that healed like a lot yeah I didn't get
any heal items I had some stuff but it
wasn't that yeah I didn't get a heal
item yeah
wow wow that guy one shot's hard how
much damage did I do wait I like 120
000. it's Mark can I look at my damage
look I would be beating you but you had
10 more minutes alive I'm gonna bust out
a calculator you had oh I was two-thirds
of your time alive so two-thirds of of
uh uh of uh so what you're saying is I'm
not only a better damage dealer I'm also
a better Survivor no no no no no no hang
on what this is that's not the metric of
which I'm comparing that I'm better than
you okay guys Mark just said I'm better
than him he did just say that no no no
no no no no no no no no no no times two
divided by three is 118 000. I did 130
000 in my time alive I did more damage
than you so I am better than you
no because you died more no that's not
I'm gonna take my side on this one what
no I agree with Bob Bob come on
are we doing this some more I mean yeah
I have a little time okay I don't know I
didn't know how late you guys had I mean
I could do it again let's just hope you
stay alive this time Hey listen I will
stay so alive
that you will wish I were dead all right
Mark we have to get our stuff and not
die this time all right so just uh make
sure you tell Wade that wait all right I
told him tell Mark to get his stuff oh I
missed my gopher thing you hear that Bob
Wade misses a gopher what a nerd right
yeah stupid what a sexy nerd who I would
love to just touch
all right guys probably get my hand
greasy or something
yeah I would like that nah I wouldn't I
don't like grease or oil or baby oil
slathered all over me I don't like that
yeah I definitely don't like slug all
over your face no no way no enough uh
snail though
wait wait no way no big nose on that one
there's not much spawning on me are you
guys fighting much I've got like nothing
to kill over here I got I got tons of
things to kill I'm so killing I'm
killing so good Bob I'm I'm killing a
lot
I believe it oh I see it I see it so I
believe it I believe in and I see it
yeah you should I do I would good great
I could even
great maybe they're scared of me maybe
they know Mark's the easier Target maybe
they know that you're the Dumber Target
and won't know if 10 000 or or two are
coming at you because you can't I don't
know when you turned against me Mark we
used to get along I don't know what
happened I got a boogly feather I don't
care I I want you to have it Bob I want
you no you deserve it no one of you
[ __ ] that jumps around a bunch I
don't jump I've never jumped just so
Mark doesn't get it I've never jumped in
my life see that's just spiteful Mark's
being friendly Mark's being he's trying
to be a bro I was trying to do some uh
double entender so he would go get it
double a long time I bet you don't even
know what that means it means double the
entender
pretty easy okay all right okay you know
what you know them more than me is that
what you wanted to hear you know more
okay fine you know more
fine and it and you I you're and you're
you look good you look good without hair
thanks man yes would you [ __ ] me and
I didn't say no
that was a pretty non-yes answer it was
a pretty non-no answer
that's I guess if you're trying to be
optimistic wait where's the uh did you
grab the feather already marked yes I
did oh you didn't get it yet [ __ ] it's
up and then to the left yeah go no you
were in the exact right place where are
you going what are you doing is it up
here
empty Bob you see you see what I mean
everything you see what I've been
dealing with I see it no you don't wow
this looks an awful lot like a feather
wrong
oh I got a feather I got a hoppo feather
I told you I found a mumbly do feather
mumbly do you know a little Ringo
feather dude Bob if you found me a
mumbly feather I would be so grateful
right I would be so grateful right yeah
yeah I'm very grateful about the mumbles
Kool-Aid now for that [ __ ] it's too late
for that now Wade whatever your name is
me Bob's mine no Bob's not yours Bob is
not a possession free [ __ ] yeah the
certificate of ownership no
does he Bob does he
you know that I hold up in Corpus yeah
but that's diff that's for my that's
different okay what's it for why is it
different for my soul
oh sort of it's sort of unrelated to
takes one to own one look I'm gonna do
the teleporter okay I don't I'm gonna
find a way out of this conversation
thank you for the opportunity to have
this conversation yeah thank you don't
press no don't copy don't copy me Wade
it's all right I really needed this
other thing that I was saving up for
that you uh didn't let me get no one
cares you can get it after the fighting
is over yeah
I don't care that much yeah you don't
care that much and I I guess we don't
care that much about you either I know
that's why you all left me alone yeah
well maybe maybe you smell bad how would
you know you're not here to know me I've
just it never happened I'm guessing I
miss my pigeons I don't have my pigeons
anymore I miss my bustling fun guy well
you could have had an extra one last
game I don't know what happened to it
man maybe you should get your memory
checked Wade your brain seems to be
broken uh maybe you should get it
checked for me hey no
too busy
playing playing the game oh it's plastic
pidgeonis I mean wax quails wax whales
[ __ ] I got my Quail I haven't
got mine guy gave me okay all right wait
you he was eyeballing Bob he was
eyeballing my whale
yeah I'm trying to do the thing and
trying to do a lot of things and you end
up messing it up more you know maybe you
should be positive we need some team
positivity and you just don't give that
okay all right yeah
stupid why aren't you more positive you
[ __ ] idiot God damn yeah see Chloe
agree with me be positive like me [ __ ]
hey I fully charged a teleporter without
getting hit I'm So Good Guys
congratulate me be more positive well
congrats I'm Flawless that's pretty good
positive God damn it we have a lot of
drones hell yeah man yeah I'm gonna go
buy one more so please don't leave yet
is there one or not I already hit it no
please tell me you that's a lie get back
here for forever
missing it I got it let's [ __ ] go
wait there's one more chest wait wait
wait wait one more chest oh wait one
more chest never mind's open yeah okay
there got it okay I'm good that's the
lunar never mind I don't want to spin
the lunar
wow you weren't gonna let me anyway
all right I know we had favorites I
thought we were all just got your fuel
cell I got it I got it I still got
myself let's do this [ __ ] all right
let's do this Bob I I've got I'm I'm
with you the whole time yep I'm with you
guys together too I'm only with Mark all
right hell yeah yeah
I'm only with Wade wait what no you
haven't played it out no I there's so
much more to play with play with me no I
think he's out of I think he's an
applied definitely what I'm good no play
with me not come on no I'm your toy come
on play it's fun games
no no thank you what no there's an
ultimate thing down here there's an
ultimate thing down there if you know
what I mean wink wink I'm saving my
little coincis for someone who truly
loves me me I'm me I have an energy
drink I don't drink caffeine because I I
like to keep my body natural
well you've done a piss poor job half
your body is fake no you're fake you
live in L.A everyone knows everyone in
La has fake body parts oh okay all right
well prove it have you seen all my body
parts yes
sadly many times all those bustling
fungus printers I found in other games I
took for granted I'm sorry bustling
fungus printers I'll be your bustling
fungus printer oh God I just picked up a
bustling fungus I I just I'm so sorry I
didn't do that I just Spam I spam and I
spam I'm just my reaction times are so
unbelievably high and I just like I'm
just so yeah good thing he asked for one
thing I look I get it I get it but my
reaction times are like Sub sub two
millisecond like they're not as good as
your reading isn't as good as you're
reacting I'm just like well I mean it's
just like it doesn't say the name when
it pops out okay it just looks like a
big bustling fungus I'm just saying well
I mean
like that again
yeah I hate I hate that quit trying to
hit me and hit me you're gonna get
copyright claimed that was a that was a
movie quote your Channel's done oh yeah
everything's a movie quote because they
all steal my quotes
I was just doing a lap to save up to buy
these things and Wade came over my area
oh wait what about one thing what the
hell wait whoa dude say anything
dude oh man you said nothing about hey
I'm saving up for this whoa whoa getting
a little
antagonistic oh sorry I'm chilling in my
inner Mark okay oh getting a little
sassy now do we have so many things it's
getting hard we really need the thing I
have so many drones I don't know where
the thing is oh I found it I'm at it get
it hit it all right let's figure that
[ __ ] you have your uh Shield bubble I
wouldn't rely on that Wade it hurt a lot
how are we feeling we chilling yeah eat
it eat it eat all of this eat all right
dude I'm giving them the business I very
much died a painful death Bob am I right
oh Mark you decided to finally come join
the fight that's nice of you I've been
here the whole time man just playing
distraction trying to keep him off of
Bob's back but uh you know I I can only
shoulder so much of this look at those
coins Bob I'll let you have two of those
that's pretty cool yeah yeah see I'm
pretty cool I let him have two when you
died I was the first to give two not
none of this competition but I want it
oh actually you should take that other
one mark why oh it doesn't really help
me it reduces damage you take while
sprinting right right makes sense makes
sense it would have been good for it
would have been good for Wade would have
been good yeah yeah like I don't have to
I don't have to run away that often
because I usually just stand there like
a badass yeah you totally know what
you're doing and didn't die at all yeah
yeah yeah totally absolutely yes all
right I walked into that one that's fair
this is a new thingy a new area oh nice
I like careful because in some of these
areas there's some dudes who will
[ __ ] straight up murder you oh found
a bustling fungus I'm a coming oh Bob
you found the the portal already great
job good job well done
yeah kiss ass am I right Bob yeah
whatever you got some brown on your nose
earlier now now
brown cow we all hate Wade yeah you're
right you're right you're right we do no
one more than me bum bum picked up fuel
cell oh wait I didn't need that at all
that's an equipment thing ah damn it
sorry Bob I should have given that to
you I know you needed fuel cells fungus
see that time I didn't I didn't I didn't
just run it over like Wade yeah like
where what'd I do like where yeah you
did it admit it just admit it you did
when I gave Bob all the funguses and
never took any for myself unlike you
admit your guilt admit your guilt we
might want to go ahead and tremolo that
uh teleportation device what is this guy
doing oh
God I didn't know that I didn't know I
didn't know oh God are you guys okay
yeah we're good what's up with you
drilling we're chilling you screamed it
got really quiet and I just want to make
sure that you weren't like you know dude
we're good uh everything's cool why
don't you want to hit that doodadder
wait give me give me a second I've
almost got this incinerator thing I said
you hit it so where was this thing I
know you marked it but I don't see it
marked anymore I'm going to it actually
a couple more things we can buy over
here Mark since we're here I got a good
bit of gold else over here it's more art
all my attacks explode [ __ ] yeah oh my
God that sounds nice what are we dealing
with
oh big guy that's a teapot it's a teapot
friends I believe they're about to do
the big suck yes yes they are doing the
suck this is my favorite part you like
the big sock oh I like the big sock the
big socks my favorite I like to standing
near my turrets and not doing anything
dude and the and the banner that you get
when you level up it's just like this is
a Kill Zone how do you know how many
lunar coins you have uh on the top left
the bottom uh thing is your coins I've
got ten is that good yes that's how many
you need oh really yeah I've got enough
for the character uh someone who
incredible by me what everyone got their
chronobles now oh wait wait no hang on
oh I got my Chrono Bobble that's
actually really great for my turrets
wait God wait you picked up two I did
not did it no oh my God you did you suck
Wade I knew it I knew it I knew it I
knew it I knew it he was out Bob man
that sucks Bob punish him
um punish him this is the place uh guys
follow me I don't have it anymore uh
Mark follow me I'm here where where'd
you go up here walk carefully
not careful enough oh God oh God
oh Jesus follow me I have a new plan uh
hang on let's we're going over to this
blue thingy oh God all right coming oh
that's a big lizard oh this is the same
place and there's bad guys here now
sweet Jesus running away oh boy okay I'm
going up okay so I just gotta run on
this chain right yeah just hop hop over
the city parts and don't let them do it
to you okay oh God oh God every time or
Mark there's a better way I have a
better plan you do come come follow okay
follow me okay coming mark we need to do
this I have to do this I will not I will
not here you can heal up in here if you
want and I'll put a little thingy down
oh it's okay I'm good where's this go
right here
we do that why okay and then do the
other blue one right here okay okay
I'm coming wait you found the right
place actually I'm coming don't jump
jump jump jump this way this way okay
okay okay jump jump I jumped I jumped I
jumped do I slam it in ah
I slammed
I did it it's right here oh all right
all right cool all right let's keep
going
whoa bouncy lizard lizards up there guys
here oh we know where the teleporter is
we should buy some [ __ ] I guess oh we
got another feather we we got another
fur yeah we got another feather what do
you mean we I mean there's no I in team
but there is a ween
he's right he's also right
they're both right I don't know how to
deal with this increase jump height
that's a cool one land on top of people
well hey Bob or Mark whoever you are
what's up what's up hey how you doing oh
I'm great how are you good good killing
stuff doing cool things tricks tips
subscribe to my YouTube channel
it costs 42.44 in here 42-40 geez oh
topaz barrier brought bro oh get wrecked
we're getting close right I just I'm
trying to save up for that 4200 chest oh
okay okay possible that's possible it's
not like it's gonna get any more harder
than what it's at right now right you
guys Papa likey the heels stop calling
yourself Papa okay big daddy likey the
heels I I don't know if that's any
better but yeah well I mean I'm precise
Grandpa likey The Lovin oh I have the
muns I think go for it man get it it is
a oh so someone else can get a a weight
Can I stack behemoths someone else come
get this it's a really good item even if
they do stack it's it's worth two of us
having it go for it gotcha now all of
your attacks curse blood now let's do
the thing come come my friends hey I'm
here okay I did it oh boy there you go
I'm gonna go high ground with my stuff
magma worm good thing we got this
careful aim of mine incredible really
it's astonishing how good I am at
hitting oh there's two never mind if you
get into trouble
try and get yourself within my fun guys
hi magma guys oh my hearts ah no oh God
no
that's what I was thinking oh God yeah
they really don't like you what get off
my turrets you shitlords
okay cool are you going all the way over
there douche
where are you going I hope you're not
talking to me no no no no my footings
were slightly I wouldn't talk to you
like that did that worm just run away no
it's coming back oh there it is
yeah okay now wait well give me one of
these cool bandolier pretty good yeah we
can all get one of those that's all
right yeah when can I go buy this um
character with the coins uh we have to
find the place from the snow level we
have to go to the hell uh there's a
separate warp to the market there's a
lunar item that's called the Newt uh
thing you have to give that a coin to
get into it we have so many drones yeah
we got a lot yeah the text is starting
to overlap the health bars it's all
right it's all right it's all right snow
level
that's nice damn it oh my God look at
our little hover back here this is the
noodle I'm gonna give a nude altar a
coin so that we can get it next time for
the special portal well what the hell I
just grab
my junk a lot of Flyers this time around
yeah but you don't have to aim at them
it's not like I have to aim at them not
like it's hard way it has Wade doesn't
have to aim [ __ ] auto guns over there
auto guns Mark why are you complaining
about that no I wanna both of you don't
have to aim do I want a bear or a
necklace
time I have to aim what the [ __ ] you
talking about with your guns your
turrets I haven't made launcher is my
gun yeah I need your expert advice Bob
what about my expert advice what's that
green spiky thing uh where it's up in
the sky it's weird I've never seen it
before Oh I like flying around yeah it's
a it's a wisp oh that's simple oh my God
those hurt oh not the green Smokey thing
there's a spike thing it's weird huh
where is it I I I killed it I killed it
I swear it was up there it was big huge
uh are we all brought up one more
there's a few more here give me a give
me up second heading your way oh another
healing drone we need that well yeah
I've bought a healing drone this round
too mechanic repair 30 drones or turrets
wow all right I'm doing the thing where
you at Mark oh wait there's a healing
chest but I don't have enough gold for
that so how much is it it's five all
right I've got that much I already said
all right that's dips that's dibs
ABS I like our Fleet of drones go drones
all right let's do this thing oh hold on
there's something spiky green monster
right here that's what I was saying yeah
weird where where I'm hitting here hey
mind if I hit this thing wait the spiky
goody spiky oh that guy is bad he he has
a debuff that he gives you that makes it
so you don't heal if this thing hits you
he's dead now all right do it Mark there
we go good luck what what it's two big
giants watch out for the lasers oh no
I'm way up in the sky ah
don't laugh it was terrifying that's the
most Family Guy style reaction to a
crisis I've ever heard
oh God they punch you up they punch you
up yeah when they punch you it's super
[ __ ] bad news he is mad yeah he is
and it's kind of hot
oh blue
a blue portal go in the Blue Portal wait
get the things ah I'm getting all the
Titanic knurls since you suckers didn't
do it what God damn it [ __ ]
you suck Bob I came to get my knurls he
hit the thing we we were honestly I had
to grab him no I had to grab them I
didn't have a choice no wait wait who
hit the thing who hit the thing who hit
the thing everyone Wade Wade I I oh he
grabbed the knurls I went to get one and
he ran back to the portal don't put this
on me of course this is your fault this
is the guy you're free
I don't have I don't have enough what
else can you buy in here it's been
lunars over here and you can uh sack
items at the other one to like get these
I don't think the other ideas is
particularly good I've only got one
lunar right now all right well I mean I
have six I spent one to get in here so
Wade you could at least like thank me
for literally the reason you're here
what oh all right I could thank you then
you know what I mean Wade yeah yeah I
mean I mean you
feel like you all right let's go
all right Bob thanks for telling us
about this place yeah you're welcome I
sacrificed a lot to be here what Mark
you complaining about something no I'm
not complaining about anything I would
never complain which I had Titanic
neural dude yeah I wish I had that too
it sounds like it's really cool it is
it's so cool you have no idea get your
energy drinks right here
uh I'd rather have a knurl well there
aren't any so why don't you just shut
the fish ass up
well I mean and wait why are you
laughing at you don't have neurals
either no I sure don't oh my God the
beetle Queens over here hurts it hurts
us is there [ __ ] to buy here I'm not
talking to either of you so maybe there
is maybe there isn't I don't know is
that are you mad because of the neural
still I am yes very extremely excessive
I don't know why you're being so [ __ ]
to him yeah well I mean just I'm [ __ ]
I'm not I mean I'm not [ __ ] I'm not
[ __ ] to anybody I'm the least [ __ ]
of all of us listen Mark huh what I know
you're being real I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead never mind my gift what
happened wait what I don't know
something over here is [ __ ] murdering
though what wait I was like full health
what hit me should we try and do it and
see if we can get out of this [ __ ]
probably go for it I believe in you guys
it's relatively calm over here right now
I have a lot of action on me might be
why that's the case my 13 Health drones
please heal me
away so heels you've got you had like
six Health drones on you at the same
time I get I got like nothing on me yeah
the health drones are pretty baller
let's do this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh dear
that's a lot of those things oh I'm
[ __ ] dead oh if I fell I actually
have five Health he'll be hail me
how did that work oh God it's not
working oh they [ __ ] killed my things
oh wow wow wow all right Wade you got it
I'm trying but I can't I can't even stay
healed with all these [ __ ] drones if
only someone shared the Titanic knurls
Oh my God the Titanic neurals might have
saved us
my God Wade you did double both of our
damage how'd you do so much oh my God
holy [ __ ] that does a lot of damage
that's a lot of damage what did you do I
do a lot of damage man oh
oh what are you what are you doing what
are you doing hey I got the I got the
power plant so that's pretty cool oh
aren't you too cool oh sorry sorry
there we go that's what I'm talking
about
[Music]